estamos en la loma de la cruz aquí en
cali uno de los principales epicentro de
protesta desde el miércoles 28 de abril
y hoy los manifestantes se han vuelto a
reunir para entre otros motivos celebrar
que el presidente iván duque finalmente
ha retirado la polémica ley de la
reforma tributaria el pueblo experto y
hoy estamos demostrando que unidos vamos
a salir adelante y esto lo vamos a
demostrar no solamente con la tumba de
la reforma tributaria sino el día de las
urnas en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales pero no todo es
celebración entre los manifestantes aquí
en la loma de la cruz y es que en los
últimos días desde el miércoles 28 de
abril ha habido distintos reportes de
organizaciones humanitarias de abusos y
violaciones de los derechos humanos por
parte de la fuerza policial de verdad la
violencia contra las marchas pacíficas
ha llegado a un límite que ya es
inhumano es inhumano ver cómo llega a
gente que está bailando que está
cantando que está solo disfrutando y les
tiran quesos lacrimógenos solo para que
pare la marcha una marcha que es
pacífica a pesar de la retirada de la
polémica ley de la reforma tributaria
del gobierno
está por ver cómo van a avanzar las
marchas en los próximos días y es que
muchos manifestantes ya no piden solo la
retirada de la reforma sino también la
dimisión del propio iván duque y es que
los efectos en colombia' de la pandemia
han sido devastadores con una pobreza
que llega al 42 por ciento en una
pandemia que precisamente en este
momento está en su tercera ola la más
crítica hasta el momento